hi my name is Maci Fung today I will be
telling you the five signs you are ready
to share your personal story with an
audience my life is a dance I
experienced mania which is happiness and
sunshine and on the other end I
experience depression which is sadness
and my melodic song becomes mellow in
between we have the intricate symbols
from the universe and everything is
intertwined as you can see my illness
quote-unquote schizoaffective disorder
is not a curse but rather a blessing in
disguise without further ado I will be
telling you my personal story
my mother and father grew up during the
Vietnam War in China and Vietnam where
the experience poverty and unrest then
they immigrated to America for the
American Dream where my sister brother
and I have better opportunities in high
school I was very shy I was not
confident however I worked very hard to
get good grades because I know how much
my parents sacrificed for us by the time
I was 18 years old I was diagnosed with
schizoaffective disorder which in my
case is a combination of schizophrenia
and manic depression I experienced my
first blow of mania and I was elated and
yeah share my opinions about caring
about other people's perceptions of me
during this time I really bond it with
my family for the first time especially
my sister was there for me every step of
the way she took me out on outings and
she treated me as a good sisterhood
I wanted to capture my experience so I
decided to make my very first short film
cut a ripple in time which is about two
sisters and the uncertainty which lies
with schizoaffective disorder and the
future our film was praised and
commended at the scary cop Film Festival
in San Francisco and I knew that I
wanted to hold on to this moment so at
that point I knew that I want to be a
filmmaker that is my dream the universe
gave me symbols and it told me that my
mission in life is to end poverty with
awareness through dance by 2030 so I
carried this mission with me everywhere
but for several years I was so lonely I
had no team members I was just on my own
and then I got into a huge episode of
depression I could not get out of bed
for weeks on end I couldn't bring myself
to do anything however I stayed true to
myself and as they say when the people
is ready
the master arrives I was opened and
welcomed into communities
to me as I am they are caring and they
are kind of course it's through me being
courageous stepping out of my comfort
zone and putting in a great deal of
effort that my communities continue to
encourage me to grow and we feed off of
each other's positive energy okay so now
that I've told you my personal story I
would like to share with you by science
you are ready to share your personal
story with an audience number one you
have immersed in your story you have
lived it when was the last time you
really truly felt alive for me it was
when I experienced mania to be alive
means you experience happiness longing
wants creativity and you meet a lot of
people along the way who shape your life
path of course at this stage you also
have to have reflected on your
experiences and feelings as well as your
emotions number two you are able to tell
your personal story in front of a lot of
different people at networking events
and social gatherings as a filmmaker I
naturally have to share my personal
story and pitch it a lot of times so
what I do at these networking events I
tell my story and this time is quite a
bit of uncertainty I am not sure if
people are interested in my story if
they resonate with me or they even are
interested in talking to me and most of
the times I thought that the answer was
no however further along my life journey
I realized that conference
is a two-way street you have to listen
to the other person's story and you have
to find an alignment number three you
are comfortable with your story at the
stage I didn't care about what people
felt about my personal story at all at
this point in my life I am able to just
say it truly and genuinely and when I
radiated this confidence I fell in love
for the world and it loved me right back
it is a wonderful magical feeling number
four at this stage you're able to tell
you a personal story in front of a big
audience full of people or online
through viewers and readers I'm able to
be vulnerable and be true to myself and
put my whole stuff out there a lot of
people have expressed gratitude to me
for sharing my story number five last
but not least you feel your biggest
dreams and ambitions within your reach
as a filmmaker my dream is to make my
drama feature film dance for peace based
on my personal story I'm able to keep
going on my dream every single day
despite constant challenges and
heartbreaking stings or projection you
just keep going and going and going and
you have faith that one day your dreams
will come true
at this time you also have to have a
place of peace and from
that is alameda beach where I have grown
up your life story is always evolving
all the way up until your last breath
and you